all right well we could probably do a
show just on Facebook but let's let's
move to the others because in a certain
way I think Facebook is becoming
increasingly irrelevant at least in the
political space I yeah my judgment of
that may be slightly off but I just
don't see that much traction anymore
with young people do you think that's
basically fair I disagree I think that
Facebook I think that the majority of
these companies disseminate their
content through the social media
platforms so I think that there are
always gonna be relevant and there's
they dominate the market in terms of
advertising revenue even even the big
news organizations disseminate their
content through Facebook so I think it's
I think they are relevant I don't know I
don't know what the trajectory of that
is yeah I don't mean that they're
irrelevant but it seems to me that the
the conversation that I really think is
important about all this seems to be
happening much more on Twitter I do not
necessarily that the money in the
advertising and the mainstream media
reach and all the things aren't relevant
on Facebook but that that the real sort
of the gestalt of this or something is
on Twitter and YouTube so it's a let's
shift there for a second you know
Twitter I'm sure you see me tweeting
when I'm about the shadow bands and the
rest of it so what the hell is going on
with Twitter well we went we went
undercover into Twitter and last year in
early 2018 and we caught a number of
engineers describing shadow banning
removing posts when people don't know
that they're sharing their content they
don't know that they're being banned
that we actually have quotes from the
engineers talking about what they have
done I mentioned earlier this direct
messaging expert guy named praticing who
works on the Twitter DM team says that
he can peruse all of your messages your
private DMS he says that there are
keywords that Twitter uses to filter
tweets the American flag god guns and
then that we talked to another Angela
might jump over the first one there so
they can literally look at your direct
messages that's what they you are
private direct messages they said they
have teams this has got in Clay hain so
they have hundred hundreds plus of
people the
and he says quote I've seen a lot of
dick pics unquote so I understand they
have to do some of this to to ban
pornography and you know gore and
content but apparently this is what they
told us I don't know why they'd have to
look at your private messages right
and they've also said that they don't do
that right so that's the thing why do
they say one thing in public another
thing in private is what we've found but
when Piggy and I try to only speak to
what I can actually a videotape of what
the engineer said right and this a banal
fedorova guy was there was a
congressional hearing where the lobbyist
Ted Cruz did ask him do you do this and
he says we do not do that well then why
did your engineer say they were doing it
mm-hmm so I just think they're being
dishonest so that's the type of sort of
underhanded tactic than they're using
the shadow baiting because you have no
idea again you just don't know when you
put something out is this getting to all
of my people or is it not or scan some
people not retweet it or the rest of it
I mean it's pretty clever if they were
trying to silence people it's a pretty
clever way of doing it I think that's
the unethical part they don't tell
people that they are doing and they
don't tell people their political
positions I just want them to be
transparent I think Facebook kind of
thing not to go back to Facebook but
they put out a thing we are banning
white nationalists well at least they're
telling us where they stand I'm not the
not that that is a good thing white
nationalism but if they were to do more
of that sort of thing and say we are we
are taking an editorial perspective of
the New York Times The Washington Post
you can see on the op-ed pages what they
believe in there they're rather
transparent about it I would say more so
so I think these companies should take
an editorial position but when when we
hear print I sing at Twitter on the
hidden camera say who talks like that
who talks about God and the American
flag and guns must be a Russian bot says
pranaya sing at Twitter well I'm fine
with that as long as you say it publicly
as long as you make it part of your
editorial position so that people know
okay this company is is extremely
left-wing do any of the bannings or any
of this ever happened to people on the
Left I know there are some instances
maybe with anti-fog accounts or a couple
things like that but it always seen
it's like you have conservatives and
people on the right talking about yeah I
don't not to my knowledge I think it are
reporting overwhelmingly focused on one
even mentioned Donald Trump's account
and insinuated that they were that they
were working with the government to to
give information to I don't know deep
state individuals this is clay Haynes a
network security engineer at Twitter
told us about Donald Trump's accounts
I've never seen anything on the other
end of the spectrum from from my vantage
point when Trump's account got taken
down for those couple hours and then it
turned out to be just what was it they
said it was some accident some young
yeah low level guy did it for you that
must have been like a whoa that just
shows you the power that any any
individual here would have access to be
able to shut down the president for our
for our purposes we're always - I'm
always trying to prove it like I want to
get them on tape admitting why they did
it but there are there are these you
know I guess you could call them
low-level people that do things that are
not acceptable and it's policed moreso
at Facebook I would say yeah anything
else going on with Twitter that's all
that we reported on the Shadle banning
the the the the private DM messages and
the shadow banning were the big ones
what do you make generally of the
political it is a ssin of twitter like
specifically so you know if you were to
just click on the search bar on twitter
on any given day and you see the twitter
moment it's oh you know they're always
showing you the trans story of the day
or whatever the left is leaning with
that day they're always sort of pushing
that down your throat is that just
consistent well anything else you view
these companies that's what I will say
is that we have more stories coming on
that sort of thing so I would I would
hold my tongue because I don't want to
scoop myself we got a number of people
on the inside that are that are maybe
focusing on the search functions at
these organizations so we'll you'll be
you have to stay tuned to see what we on
yeah that wouldn't surprise me I mean
when I search certain people even if
they're verified if they happen to be on
the right sometimes they don't pop up
but I get a zillion random accounts
before that or I often think that the
the trending tab right seems like it's
completely manipulated you know what
they
commenting on and what they're you know
because sometimes there's a comment
beneath the trend or whatever it all
just seems made up and and and for
project Veritas the the priority is to
prove it is to is to catch them on tape
admitting it and that is what we will do
and we will have more stories soon on
all this alright so let's move to
youtube we're on YouTube right now I've
had people in the past years ago when I
did and one time I did have an email
address of someone at YouTube and they
told me because I kept saying people
keep complaining that their unsubscribe
from my channel I kept getting emails
every day and one time someone from
YouTube admitted to me they said there's
a bug on your channel and we're trying
to work it out with a couple weeks after
that after I followed up a few times and
then I couldn't get in more information
I got an email from the guy saying I'm
no longer handling this case and now you
have to go to the you don't have an
email address to respond to anymore go
to the general tab and complain or
whatever so I have to publicly shame
them all the time you probably see me
doing this with team write to you on
Twitter every time I get demonetised I
fight them and then they usually not
always Lila Rose for example they did
not
Ramanna ties they didn't read not remit
really monetize that one it was
demonetized by the algorithm and then
confirmed by manual review now that's
their right to do that again you want
some transparency with it but
unsubscribes
videos not going out to feed all of
these things what what evidence do we
actually have that these things are at
well we did a story in 2017 between a
New York Times reporter named Nick Dudek
and YouTube and again I can only talk
about what I report that's my rule so I
don't I don't like to comment on things
that I don't I haven't had personal
experience with but there was a
relationship between these networks like
the New York Times and hopping a post
and and YouTube and their there are
favors given to to these organizations
over say your show and and that's
something that we've we reported on and
exposed so what would a favor look like
well preferential treatment and into
getting into the the Scientifics of it
I'm not sure but preferential treatment
where the video would would which
more frequently at the top of the of the
search query it's this guy Nick Dudek
who was a social accounts video editor
for The New York Times talked about his
relationship with this guy inside
YouTube so there's there's a sort of but
you know two-way street there between
the two companies where favors are done
but with the New York Times now why are
they doing them favors I that's what I
was talking about earlier where these
companies have enormous power because
even the likes of the old media transmit
their messages through the new media
that's where the majority of people get
their information from so but that that
was that guy Nick Dudek actually the
executive editor of the New York Times
Dean Beck a is his name actually we
believe let that guy go he actually
terminated Nick Dudek for telling us
this stuff no one reported on that but I
don't know whether they terminated him
for telling the truth or for or for
lying about what he had said so how do
you combat that the part where every
time you guys release something that I
look at it I'm always hesitant to
retweet it I've shared some of your
videos sometimes but I'm always like I
if this is the one where you know he got
duped or you know it's only being shared
by Breitbart or whatever that then it's
like you know you like basically that
you have some sort of secondary layer of
censorship to get through well I'll tell
you what we've done - you know - because
Huffington Post and BuzzFeed and CNN
well they have touched it I mean
Anderson Cooper reported on this stuff
we did during the 2016 election on
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump our
stories in the 2018 election made the
New York Times we've gotten a lot of
local media coverage we've been in terms
of being duped we've in out of 200
undercover investigate they say things
are edited they're edited out of context
they're they're not real I mean and you
actually ask them what specific edits
are you talking about because to say
that video is edited and it's like
saying words are arranged all journalism
is edited in to tell a story and they
say well you didn't were the pimp
costume and the acorn office well you
know okay but I presented myself as a as
a pimp
and even the New York Times said that
and pimp protocol doesn't require
wearing a copy of him they were a big
pink jacket a drive a Cadillac uncle and
I said well there was a scene change in
the NPR investigation okay is that the
best you got I mean the idea was a
cutaway shot where the guy was laughing
and I was narrating over it in 200
investigations I mean they've printed
300 corrections and retractions about me
I have a wall on my office called the
wall of shame and it's all these
Corrections and retractions about me
Washington Post said I went after acorn
due to an animus about african-americans
voting they made it up Pulitzer
prize-winning reporter Carolina just
made something up out of whole cloth so
there I don't know I think there is a I
think it's not about the that what we do
is real the tapes you see there's never
been a case where we saw it wasn't real
there was one thing with the Washington
Post that blew up they turned their
cameras back around on us and everyone
you know so well that's unethical what
exactly it was unethical about it
because we went undercover into CNN we
infiltrated something called 'rain Bros
which was a gay group where this
producer was in nobody questioned the
ethics of it nobody questioned the
ethics because the end was so obvious
and whether or not you think that the
means are justified depends upon whether
you think there's a compelling public
interest and what you are exposing so
when these things get interrupted then
people say it's unethical but we think
that undercover work is justified
particularly into the big ten companies
in the big media due to the urgency of
the circumstances but in all of our work
no one no one's ever able to actually
say what exactly has been fake about it
and that's from my perspective sorry are
you shocked at actually how the collapse
of mainstream media has precipitated so
quickly at this point like it seems to
me that it's just it's over I mean now
just in the last couple of weeks now
with with Trump and Russia and just
where I'm out that these people have
just lied over and over and finally
thanks to Twitter and YouTube and the
rest of it if we're not being shadow and
everything right there's enough of us
that can get a counter-narrative
out there but they just keep doing it
well I said I think it's
death of I think it's it's you've
covered because I watch your show a lot
of the political reasons why media is
dying but I actually think it's goes
back to Jeffers sucker said in the last
two weeks about if you saw that tweet
where brian Stelter said or not
investigators well that was an
unbelievable moment because that's
really they're not they're not
investigative reporters and people have
to remember thing about CNN what CNN
yeah CNN we don't run out of
investigators we're journalists so
here's the thing this is very important
people talk about politics people talk
about you know the media's algorithms
but it's also economics investigative
reporting is very very expensive and
it's a naturally philanthropic activity
investigative reporting going back 40 50
years it was always a loss leader on the
company's balance sheets people have to
remember these are these are businesses
they're not interested in the public
interest they're interested in in
generating a profit and that's fine but
but don't pretend that you serve the
public interest we had a CNN insider on
tape john bond afield said this is a
business the CEO of CNN Jeff Zucker told
us stop talking about the climate
Accords let's get back to Russia
he's about ratings it's not about ethics
and it's been I think it's important to
illustrate though you're not saying
there's anything inherently wrong with
that he's allowed to make money he's
allowed to do business but but don't
pretend you're operating in the public
interest because investigate reporting
and let me let me you would mention that
you know people don't people are wary of
what we do it's naturally the tip of the
spear you have to use deception to a
degree either you deceive your source or
you deceive your audience
the problem with journalism and the
reason why it's in decline is because
these leakers these sources and
government and elsewhere intentionally
transmit stuff to the media and they
parrot it to the masses AIE Jeff Zucker
saying we don't investigate what we're
told and that's what you know what what
has been referred to as a pseudo event
they create something they transmit it
unquestionably and there's the economic
factor there's a symbiotic relationship
between people and power what we do at
Veritas
is we go undercover and we we completely
defy the narrative and that's and most
networks don't want to air it because
because it's risky because it's
questioning the the normative order of
things it's easier to do little videos
about squirrels on skateboards and I did
this big story during the election you
know the free Bob Kramer resigned from
the Hillary Clinton campaign and a lot
of these companies say we're afraid that
if Hillary Clinton wins we shall take
away our FCC license so it's it's it's
this it's this economic issue that is
inherent in media and it requires
independent people to do something about
it because the networks are not going to
do something about it they are they're
in the business of generating a profit
it's so fascinating to me because it's
like they're not even in the business
right I get it so they're in the
business making a profit that's fine
that is what business is but they're not
even in the business of pretending
anymore because it's like during the
whole Mueller investigation every week
there was another leak to the New York
Times and it's always an anonymous leak
and then for the last two years they ran
anonymous leak stories and it's like
shouldn't if somebody had been
investigating why the Mueller operation
is leaking that actually would have been
a story right where was that story out
of the New York Times
well they had and James clapper and and
John Brennan and these are intelligence
grabber who lied under oath
these are intelligence agency people and
maybe not the most always ethical people
and they're just parroting what they're
told on TV things are when things are
and again I go back to this whole
distinction and because when you when
you report from a podium when you say
something at a press conference the the
damage to society done by broadcasting
what you are told on the record is often
more pernicious than the damage that say
I do by deceiving some guy in a bar so
that I can get the truth out of them it
is a it is a huge difference and and I
think that journalists tend to be that
you sort of have to play confidence
games you know you have to seduce your
source so to speak but there's there's
there's a - there's a relationship
between sources and the media that I
think has become corrupt
I think that the the anonymous or the
reliance upon anonymous sources has
become corrupted you look at Bob
Woodward legendary reporter I think is a
great journalist by the way I don't
think these journalists are bad
journalists I don't even think they're
bad people I think they're part of an
industrial system of production that
manufactures the public's consent but
look at Bob Woodward he writes a book
called fear and he he uses quotes
secondhand from anonymous sources on the
background on deep background hearsay
quotes and then he recreates events and
he puts that those events in quotation
marks and I get attacked for selective
editing I don't report anything unless
you can hear and see it come out of the
person's own mouth so I think that I
think that journalism has become
corrupted due to this over reliance upon
sources anonymous sources especially and
I think that that's why we need
videotapes I literally remember being in
like junior high school and watching CNN
and they would say a source on Capitol
Hill and I would always think this is
insane a source on Capitol anyone can be
on Capitol Hill it could be the guy
that's walking his dog on Capitol Hill
who's the janitor for the you know
fast-food joint but we don't we don't
see us or don't we don't see that
sources face yeah we don't know what
motivates that person we don't know what
words were used you know that source it
exists we don't know if that person
exists I mean can you imagine if I said
there are sources inside CNN who says
that Jeff Zucker said they'd call me a
liar yeah and and and I and there's an
analogy here I heard someone say that
when you use an anonymous source it's
like you're taking withdrawal out of a
bank account of credibility but you have
to deposit into the bank account trust
with the audience and nowadays we don't
see these we don't see these anonymous
sources we see an over reliance upon and
every time you actually open the
reporter's notebook every time you look
at the transcript every time you see the
raw data there there is a there is a
difference between what you are told and
and by the people that are asking you to
trust them yeah but that's the bottom
line these these these media companies
don't trust us with the raw information
they don't
want us to have the raw unfiltered truth
they need to propagandize us with their
version of it yeah it's crazy once you
see it right like once you really
clearly see it like I was actually in
the greenroom with Jordan Peterson while
he was being interviewed by Nellie
Bowles who was the author at the New
York Times who made that whole brouhaha
about enforced monogamy yeah and it's
like that is not what this conversation
was about or I had a whole day here
literally an entire day from 8 a.m. to
about 8 p.m. with a journalist for a
journalist from Der Spiegel who then
wrote a piece about me and labeled me
the grand illusionist of the all right
yeah they're labeled as you know what
they did there's al I didn't know this
at the time but there's a law in Germany
that if you're gonna print something a
quote from somebody you have to get the
quote cleared so he spends all day with
me hours of talking hours and hours and
hours
he doesn't quote me one smile I mean
that's the level that what is that it's
not selective editing yeah they called
me the master of ceremonies instead of
an anchor they use the master of
ceremonies I mean it's just like what
with the Washington Post Kate there was
nothing like grandmammy The Washington
Post has printed like five retractions
just in reporting about me it's like
these guys have the audacity to claim
and I'm a liar in one article they said
what the latest project Veritas video
leaves out and the actual fact that I
allegedly left out was that this CNN
producer that we recorded was based in
Atlanta supposedly this was a big fact
but I didn't leave it out it was in the
video
The Washington Post had to print a
retraction that they didn't change the
headline what do you what the video left
out they retracted the entire thing
there's another thing in The Washington
Post about this book fear and there was
a quote that said there's no evidence
that he did not say the things
attributed to him in referencing there's
no evidence he did not this is yeah we
live in this weird world and I think
that videotape cut through all the
propaganda like a hot knife through
butter if you catch these people on
videotape they're forced to address it
and I think that video is is that's why
we choose the medium of video because
words words do not transfix in a way
that video does and I think that words
are the frankly the propagandists tool
because they put you in a box
by calling you names like that by
calling me masters of ceremonies by
calling you what you were you're not
what that is yeah you are you God I know
we could trade these stories all day
long I'll just give you one more but
that same reporter from New York Times
Nellie both she wrote the story when
Peterson and I left patreon they
actually did a story on it which was
quite shocking it's a horrible story
filled with factual errors but in there
there's a quote from the head of trust
and safety at patreon where she says you
know you're not allowed to say these
words on our platform except so as I'm
sure you know Carl Benjamins are gonna
kinda never said those words on their
platform I contacted the author and it's
like she just doesn't care and she knows
she's not gonna get fired and why even
tell the truth so it's like they just
don't one thing that people are doing in
more frequency is recording their
interviews we have these people that we
and that's something that I would
encourage as long as it's legal to do so
yeah but you're on the record so it's
it's it's legal because they're
consenting to the conversation even in
in California and we had one individual
inside CNN record Allison camera she
does long panel discussion about voter
fraud they cut the tape right before the
guy actually brought up instances so
something that people are doing now is
their audio recording these interviews
for that reason and releasing the full
interview on YouTube right so we've seen
a lot of that actually Tommy Robinson
has done that right this guy avi and he
has done that with yes this Jim Jay I
would not I would I would employ your
audience never do an interview with the
press unless you audiotape it and that's
for your own for your own protection
yeah the other thing you can do at least
in our situation is I really only do
these shows now if it's live right if
it's live you can't edit me you might be
able to sandbag me and I have to be
smart enough to work with that but you
at least can edit me said well Andrew
Breitbart was my one of my mentors and
he would take this very we were
different people but he would take this
perspective of you know just as much
press as possible I'm proudly Who I am I
guess it was a different world ten years
ago but he would do he would just give
them everything I think that there's two
different ways to play it but certainly
to record the interviews is a good a
good path and some people are leaking us
these audio tapes and we put the pub we
put the the long version out on Twitter
and Alison cammarata it's
CNN was so humiliated by this raw
version of the interview that she
actually removed she left Twitter
because people were tweeting at her Wow
all this all these angry tweets so we
talked a little bit about anonymous
sources what do you make of just like
the anonymous accounts all over the
platforms that often are the drivers of
a lot of the bad behavior so for example
there are anonymous accounts that of
twenty thirty forty thousand followers
that I see all day long selectively
editing video clips of me or just any
you know any rights and human being and
it's like they can do it with complete
impunity because their names aren't
attached to any of this and what what
are you gonna do what what do we do in
situation I mean I've got people
personating me yeah and I'm not verified
I got five hundred thousand dollars this
morning I don't know who else I guess
there's Julian Assange is also not
verified I don't know how to solve these
problems I don't know what the public
policy solutions are my my perspective
and I won't ask me what do we do about
it I say the solution is to inform the
people the solution is to show people
the rot the corruption to to rake the
muck as it were to be a muckraker to
illuminate all the problems because I
think the solutions become self-evident
when people know that there's a guy in a
room in San Francisco arbitrarily
determined well we're gonna take away
and take away the blue checkmark we
don't like that guy's politics film that
show people those conversations behind
closed doors because then they can't get
it there's impunity they can't get away
with it and and that's the so that is
the solution the solution is to expose
it what I mean I can't believe that I'm
I mean on one hand I don't want to
complain about it because it makes it me
feel like I'm you know ingratiating
myself to Twitter I'm not I'm not a
verified human being or a platform and I
and why not what is the definition of
being verified but certainly when you
are verified it does help your your
stories get out the point is that it's
people know that it's actually you and
it's yeah people many people impersonate
me I don't I don't know what the
solution is but I know that to find the
solution we have to properly identify
the problem and educate the people with
what they're saying you need a mole in
the verified depart
who can just click that button maybe we
already have one it's the own is whether
to cut bait if you will be if you will
be verified with your blue check by the
time this video goes up I will be very
impressed that would be amazing that
would be interesting somehow I think you
haven't been sitting on that one no I
well the question with undercover work
is when you cut bait because you have
these people who are in on the inside
and then you have to make an editorial
decision on when do we release the story
like we have people right now right now
as I speak inside the big networks who
work for them mm-hmm they come to me and
they are so sick by how these companies
project themselves you know all the news
is fit the print the most trusted name
in news that is not what they hear in in
the news rooms they hear they mean we
had one person say the people were
crying they were crying the night of the
election at the Washington Post
everyone was sobbing and the things that
were being said that night would shock
you so these people come to me we're
calling it the be brave initiative and
we think that the heroes are these are
these individuals on the inside and and
I think that they'll blow the whistle
they'll tape the networks and hopefully
that that will change people's
perception of big media once and for all
how do you think Trump somehow
understood this how is it that this
orange man with crazy hair somehow
understood that like this was it like oh
you know he was always sort of a Twitter
troll and yeah doing his thing and he
understood celebrity any understood
public relations and business obviously
but this very specific thing that we've
been talking about for the for the last
hour Trump really seems to understand
this do you do you have any sense of
what that is my perspective is that it
was about earned media it was about
generating our I think that there was
some something written about this where
his advisers said you can't run this
campaign on earned media alone you you
have to be more traditional I said the
hell I can't watch me and he got some I
don't know how much it was 5 10 billion
dollars in earn media yeah since this is
this notion of I think a lot of people
particularly on the conservative side of
the spectrum tend to complain about
whine about you know the mainstream
media they I call it the conservative
ghetto they stay
talking to themselves but but then
there's this other vision where you were
you you you hack the media you you you
participate in the media it's again I'm
going back to Andrew Breitbart he would
he would love to go on these shows that
the definition of success is being
covered by the mainstream media in it's
it's it's a tough dance because they
attack you they call you and Julie you
know Jordan names and those sorts of
things but if you play it the right way
and get covered by the media that's
that's real power and Trump understood
that so he could win the election with
earned media it was absolutely brilliant
nobody else saw it everyone thought he
was nuts
but he won the election on earned media
on getting these big ABC CBS NBC New
York Times to cover him to talk about
him it was brilliant it was amazing and
everyone thought he couldn't it couldn't
be done and he did it and by the way I
have the same vision although in a you
know lesser degree I I tell my team I
tell my employees the definition of
success again the front page the New
York Times because in Manhattan look
what you know people have to realize is
that if it is not in the New York Times
it does not exist they don't pay
attention to things on the outside I
hate to give them that power but it's
still true to a degree so to be
successful is to be covered by the
people that we hate and also and also
not to get stuck where we want to be
loved by those people yes because that's
the problem that is that is the problem
we want to be loved and Rush Limbaugh
says you know I learned that to be hated
as a sign of success and that's where a
lot of Republicans go wrong Trump did
not go wrong a lot of Republicans want
to be loved by the New York Times by
Politico it's tempting
I want to be loved you everyone wants to
be loved right but we're gonna be hated
for what we say and do so it's being cut
so Trump's getting covered by them but
he also calls the fake news brilliant
it's it's it's Andrew Breitbart 2.0
alright so in in summation here if you
had if you were in the predictions game
where do you see the platform's do you
sense
the way we communicate right now where
we're all on these things and we're all
subjected to these subjective rights and
seemingly arbitrary decisions and all of
those things do you sense that five ten
years from now it's gonna still be the
same or do you think that things are
gonna massively change they are only
going to change if independent citizens
have the courage and the willpower to do
something about it
I don't trust the politicians I don't
trust the people on television to do
anything about it because they're stuck
in the status quo and they're fat and
happy it's gonna require citizens
independent people you know some of
these insiders I know some of them and
others they have to blow the whistle
they have to summon the righteous
indignation I think that journalism has
the power to change hearts and minds
real investigative reporting to be the
what has been called the custodians of
conscience and if we can shock the
people show them what's going on behind
the closed doors I think it can change
things if that does not happen I think
we'll enter a brave new world where that
doesn't happen we're a long gun yeah
we're but but there are people I know
these people they're gonna blow the
whistle but if that does not happen then
we're gonna enter a brave new world but
where this story has to be so big here's
the silver lining even if we get banned
even if you get banned I get banned
everyone gets banned the stories will
come out and other people will share
them proxies will share them and they'll
share the information that that people
will have a right to know that we'll
want to see but I think it's going to
require an effort by by independent
citizens and brave Patriots willing to
blow the whistle that is the only saving
grace I can see for this country the the
heroes amongst us they can to pitch a
little bit they can go to our website
and I will give them a camera I will pay
their legal bills I will hire them if
they are fired by their employer Twitter
and Facebook have not sued me I get sued
a lot I've not been sued by those
companies they do not want to give heft
and weight to the stories that we have
unmasked they do not want to give us
free publicity so there is a strategy
here
- to hold these people accountable I'm
gonna ask you one more actually which is
I've asked this is a few of my guests
that I think are on the forefront of
saying unpopular things or doing work
that is challenging in a interesting way
what is it about you why why do you
James O'Keefe put your ass online if I
if Veritas went away tomorrow and I had
no employees
I'd be out hustling on the street with a
camcorder and this is I this is what I
was born to do like I can't do anything
else and it goes back to this whole idea
of a justice complex like the Acorn
investigation that cost me $1,000 to do
I borrowed my grandmother's chinchilla
coat a camcorder that a friend gave me
in a borrowed copy of Final Cut Pro and
a coin was defunded both houses of
Congress were democratically controlled
President Obama signed the bill it
doesn't take money to do this
it doesn't take power to do this it
takes it takes will it takes the design
takes a belief in justice it takes a
desire to it to expose something to
inform your fellow citizens and finding
people who are like-minded if they were
to take away my organization I'd be
doing this the rest of my life I had
nothing else I could do because I
believed in it I actually believed in
what I'm doing and the people that I
find I have a profound responsibility to
serve the the people to tell the truth
to the people and people coming forward
that want to blow the whistle this is
this is why Veritas now exists is to
equip those people and to protect them
I'd be willing to go to jail to protect
the source I have been to jail I've been
incarcerated I've been sued I've been
set up it's not it's not the worst thing
the worst thing is not to to serve the
people that come to me and want to tell
a story and that's why we exist and
we're going to keep doing it until
people are honest on that note you can
follow James and Project Veritas on
Twitter for as long as they're still on
Twitter it's at Project underscore
Veritas
[Music]